welcome to get cooking in cloud where we
share the best recipes to apply in your
cloud kitchen I'm Priyanka Vergara and
in this episode we will talk about
scaling of web application on Google
compute engine
[Music]
as we learned in our compute engine
example when web apps are deployed on
GCE instances deployment and scaling is
done automatically and seamlessly by
using instance templates when your
website becomes popular and the users go
from 1 to 1 million you need to add
instances and when the requests go back
down you need to remove those instances
to keep the costs low but how does
adding and removing instances
automatically work compute engine auto
scaling policies auto scaling is one of
the features of managed instance groups
managed instance groups allow you to
operate applications on multiple
identical virtual machines based on
instance templates you can make your
workload scalable and highly available
by taking advantage of automated managed
instance group services including auto
scaling Auto healing regional
deployments and auto updating but wait
what is an instance template an instance
template is a specific customized
configuration of the GCE instance that
facilitates the reuse of instance
configurations by using managed instance
groups this custom image then becomes
the starting point for future
deployments now back to auto scaling
policies our scaling policies provides a
way to add or remove instances as needed
the impact of auto scaling policies is
twofold
one your users get a great experience
using your application because there are
always enough resources to meet the
demand and two you maintain better
control over your cost because the
autoscaler removes the instances when
demand falls below a specific threshold
to create an auto scaler you must
specify the auto scaling policy and a
target utilization level that the
autoscaler uses to determine when to
scale the group you can choose to
scale using average CPU utilization
stackdriver monitoring metrics or HTTP
load balance and serving capacity which
can be based on either utilization or
requests per second the autoscaler
continuously collects usage information
based on the policy compares the actual
utilization to your desired target
utilization and determines if the group
needs to be scaled up or down for
example if you scale based on CPU
utilization you can set your target
utilization level at 80% and the
autoscaler will pull for the CPU
utilization and check if it is more than
80% if so it adds the new instance to
the instance group if the CPU
utilization is less than 80% then it
removes an instance from the group
making sure the capacity is always
maintained you can use auto scaling in
conjunction with load balancing by
setting up an auto scaler that scales
based on the load of your instances for
example assume the load balancing
serving capacity of a managed instance
group is defined as hundred requests per
second for instance if you create an
order scaler with HTTP load balancing
policy and set it to maintain a target
utilization level of 80% the autoscaler
will add or remove instances from a
managed instance group to maintain 80%
of the serving capacity or 80 requests
per second per instance now our
architecture needs to automatically
replace instances that have failed or
have become unavailable and when the new
instance comes online it should
understand its role in the system it
should configure itself automatically
and should discover any of the
dependencies and it should start
handling requests automatically to
replace a failed instance automatically
we can use several compute engine
components together you could create
instance
applets that use a public image and a
startup script to prepare the instance
after it starts running but we recommend
that you use deterministic instance
templates which minimizes risks and
unexpected behavior from your instance
templates thanks to managed instance
groups now we have a system that can
replace unhealthy instances with new
ones but we still have a challenge how
are we going to know which instance to
replace well for that we need to define
what is an unhealthy instance and to do
that we use health checks we recommend
that you use separate health checks for
load balancing and for auto healing auto
healing health checks are set up at the
managed instance group level you create
a health check that looks for a response
on port 80 and that can tolerate some
failure before it marks instance as
unhealthy and causes them to be Creek
created in this example an instance is
marked as healthy if it returns
successfully two times it is marked as
unhealthy if it returns unsuccessful
three consecutive times we learned some
tricks to make your web application
resilient by spinning up new instances
and taking them down if compute
resources fail or your traffic grows
that's all for today on get cooking in
cloud here's hoping you can whip up
something great join us next time where
we will see a journey of the startup
from a few users to thousands of users
and how they evolved their web
application architecture to meet the
growing and changing needs if you like
this video then check out the previous
episodes too and to see more such
content don't forget to Like and
subscribe to our Channel
[Music]
[Applause]